[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to this episode of
"Coffee with a Googler."
Today I have a very
special guest joining me.
Emeka has come all
the way from Nigeria.
And Emeka, he's a program
manager in sub-Saharan Africa
responsible for
working with developers
in that part of the world.
Now, he's also been working
on this awesome project which
has been about taking developer
content that's typically
only available online and making
it available to developers
offline.
So Emeka, welcome and
thanks for joining us.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Thank
you for having me, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
you're very welcome.
It's just a real treat
to have you here today.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: It's
a great day on campus
and it's great to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So tell
us about this project.
Is it "cay-sa?"
Is that how I pronounce it?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
Project Kesaa, yeah.
So "kesaa" is an Igbo word.
It's a language spoken
in southeastern Nigeria.
"Kesaa" means to distribute
or to share something that
gets to everybody, everyone.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: The
project was actually
born out of the work we're
doing in sub-Saharan Africa
working with the
developer ecosystem there.
And while doing
this, we found out
that, yes, Google does have a
lot of great developer content.
But this content
is mostly online.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: And
by developer content,
I mean stuff like the tutorials,
the videos, documentation,
installation files,
and stuff like that.
This content is mostly
available online.
But then you find out that
in sub-Saharan Africa,
a lot of the people
have internet
that is either too expensive,
or unreliable, or in some cases,
nonexistent.
Right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
So these developers
find it pretty hard to get
access to this content.
So we asked ourselves,
is there a way
that we can get this content
to them in a way that is
offline-friendly, so to speak.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: So
we tested our idea first,
with a small pilot where
we just had about 500 DVDs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: And we
got some of this content
on the DVDs.
And we ran a pilot
with a few developers.
And the response was amazing.
They loved it.
So we decided to take
it a step further.
And we actually got
a lot of content,
about 32 gigs of content, what
we call the software developer
offline kit.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Nice and compact.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
Yeah, very compact.
This one is a USB format.
It has 32 gigs of data.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sweet.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
And on it, we
had stuff like-- we had the
entire Android developer
website here.
We had the Google
Cloud documentation.
We had all the software
developer kits for Android
and cloud here.
We had documentation
on material design.
We had videos for
cloud and Android
from Google I/O and the
Google Developers channel.
And also, very importantly, we
had the Udacity course videos.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So like
the Android fundamentals,
the scalable, all that stuff.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yeah,
all that good stuff.
And we invited people who
were interested in joining us
in this pilot to apply
to get one of these kits.
And we were actually
blown away by the number
of applications we got.
We got about 4,000 people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: You
know, these responses
came from all over the world.
In fact, one of them I found
particularly interesting
was this guy who, he works
on a boat on the North
Sea for two weeks--
LAURENCE MORONEY: On a boat?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: --and he's
on land for another two weeks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: And
while he's on the boat,
I think he writes code.
So he didn't have access
to all this content,
because internet was a
challenge on the boat.
So he requested that we send him
the kit so that he could use it
while writing code on the boat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Do you
know what he was building?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: I have
no idea what he was building.
I would love to find out myself.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well, if
you're watching on this,
please just leave us a comment
below so you can tell us
what it was that you
built. Because we
would love to know
what you did while you
were on the boat in the
middle of the North Sea.
You've had folks from all
over the world downloading it.
What kind of
results did you get?
What kind of numbers
did you have?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: We
do know, at this point,
that at least 4,000
people are actively
using the content in
over 100 countries.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yeah,
so that's quite interesting.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And that's
the one's that you know.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
That's the ones we know.
Because obviously, this
content is used mostly offline.
So we don't know anything
about what goes on offline.
But when they use it while
connected to a computer,
we can tell through
Google Analytics--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
--that it's being used.
And we're going on to actually
spread this even more.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
And this content, it's like
twice a year you do it?
So you produce new content.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yes, we
try to do it twice a year.
So in fact, there is another
one due in the next few weeks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice,
I look forward to it.
So hopefully some of my
content will be in there.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
Yeah, definitely.
Definitely will be in there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now your
target developers, originally--
even though you reach global--
but your original target
developers were sub-Saharan,
Nigerian, that kind of thing.
Could you tell us a little
bit about developers
in that part of the world?
What's the profile of
a developer there like?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: The
profile of a developer
in sub-Saharan
Africa is one that
has been evolving over
the past few years.
So in the last six years
or so, the ecosystem
in sub-Saharan Africa
has come to realize
the value of the internet, not
just as a channel for reaching
their customers or end users,
but also as a growth engine
for empowering
themselves economically,
and financially, and so on.
Because of this explosion
in the last few years,
many of these startups
who have built products
that are actually
gaining traction
find themselves in
a situation where
they need to get new talent or
they need to expand their team.
And the demand actually
way outstrips the supply.
So that's actually
what keeps me awake
at night, trying to figure out
ways to grow the talent pool,
upskill more developers
for these startups to hire
and continue doing
what they're doing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
then these startups
are a great contributor to the
economy as they go forward,
right?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yes, yes.
A lot of them are doing
very great things.
For example, ecommerce
recently took off.
In Nigeria, there's a company
called Conga, for example.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: I think
they started in the last year
and a half, two years ago.
And they recently launched
their Android app last year,
right in time for the
holiday shopping season.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: And it
was a really big hit for them,
because it helped a lot
of people who are mainly
on their mobile phones
to place orders and have
these orders fulfilled.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Folks
that aren't aware of it,
in sub-Saharan Africa, the
desktop revolution kind
of passed by, right?
People have really gone
straight to mobile.
So ecommerce is mobile first.
It's mobile only rather
than mobile first--
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
Well yes, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --primarily.
So as a result then,
somebody like that
can be really successful
for the economy as a whole.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yes, indeed.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, I understand one of
the things you've also
been working on is design,
and design language,
and helping mobile developers
to design in user-centric ways.
What efforts have been
putting forward in that?
Could you share?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yes.
So with the internet--
the evolution
of the internet as a channel
and as a growth engine-- one
challenge that has come
up in sub-Saharan Africa,
and indeed, many major
market countries,
is the lack of locally
relevant content.
You know, there isn't enough of
this locally relevant content
online.
And for the internet
to be useful to people
in these regions,
they have to find
something that is useful to
them that was built for them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: For
them-- yeah, exactly.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: So a lot
of the content online right now
was built here in Silicon
Valley, or in Europe,
or wherever, and
wasn't built for they
user in sub-Saharan Africa.
So what we're trying to
get the ecosystem to do now
is to do what
Google does, right,
to focus on the
user-- in this case,
the African user-- to
build for that user
by integrating
principles of user
centered design in their
product development process.
So what we did was,
starting last year,
we started running a series
of UX master classes,
as we call them.
The whole idea was to introduce
these principles of UX design
to developers, product managers,
project managers, and so on--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
--so that they
can apply this to the
tools and the products
that they're building.
And we just had the second
iteration of that this year,
where we focused on teams
that had new product ideas
and teams that had
existing products that
were trying to iterate to
get the next version out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO:
And the result
has been quite encouraging.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
I understand, recently,
in your country,
there was an election.
And technology played
a great big part.
And Android, and App
Engine, and other stuff
played a part in that.
Could you tell us
a little about it?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yes.
The 2015 elections in
Nigeria were quite unique
for a lot of reasons.
And one of them was the role
that technology and social
played in the entire process.
But before the polls themselves,
there was this concern
that there would be some
form of voter apathy,
that people wouldn't
come out to vote.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And you can't
have democracy without voters,
right?
CHUKWUEMEKA AFIGBO: Yeah.
I mean, you just can't.
So one of the things
we did was to run
a campaign called the
Pledge to Vote campaign
where people went to a website
that was powered by Google
Cloud and they pledged to vote.
So when you did that, you
get a badge generated for you
with your name.
And you can
automatically share this
on the social platform
of your choice
and challenge your friends to
also go and pledge to vote.
So that was quite successful.
We also had various Google+
Hangouts where a number
of the candidates actually
engaged people, the press,
the public on their manifesto
and stuff like that.
So it was quite interesting,
the role that technology played.
And I think the country
was better off for it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's good to hear.
And I know there was a great
blog post on Google Africa.
We'll post a link to it here.
And so one the
things with elections
is elections are quite
close to being universal.
But we can learn a lot
from what you guys did
in Nigeria, hopefully for
our elections next year.
Emeka visited us all
the way from Nigeria.
And he shared these
amazing stories
of just the breadth of
things that developers
are doing, all because
of content that you're
able to give them offline.
So thank you so much, Emeka.
Thank you again, everybody.
If you have any
questions for me,
just leave them in
the comments below.
And if you have any
questions for Emeka,
please also leave them
in the comments below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Developers
channel for more great episodes
of "Coffee with a Googler."
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]